it is time for drew's news your daily
grading of the fresh news
parmigiano and with me at the desk is my
best co-pilot ever ross
[Applause]
first up in the news we're all guilty of
a little impulse purchase now and then
and the cut reports that nicholas cage
just revealed one of his it's a
two-headed snake and he bought it for 80
000. he said he had a dream about a
two-headed eagle and then the next day
he heard that the two-headed snake was
for sale and he was like obviously so
unfortunately it turns out
the two heads did not get along
he tried putting a spatula in between
them at feedings but he said it just got
too freaky and if it's too freaky for
nicholas cage it's gonna be freaking
yeah
but he safely returned them to a zoo you
know that when they we tell kids they
went to that far yeah yeah living in
there yeah well that's where these
snakes went uh frost thought i mean this
is something only nicholas cage would do
right a two-headed snake but the
freakiest part of the story is that the
heads didn't get along i know right
can you imagine you're a two-headed
snake for starters you're like man and
then the worst part is like you don't
like each other
what are you coming over here to be like
why come here you guys where are you
coming are we doing two headed tonight
did you ever have your phone buzz only
to look down and read a text that says
can we talk
oh my god refinery29 reports that
experts say you should never text that
to anyone
if you text we need to talk it
immediately makes people think about the
absolute worst case scenarios it's a
heart attack in a text message and
should never be done rossi thoughts
don't you dare text me this okay
just
because you know what i've done in that
18 seconds between hey
when you talk and the bubble is that
i've decided everyone died right
everyone's gone they're just dead uh
there's a bomb on the way hey you know
boom uh so every single worst case
scenario um you know they they canceled
bridgeton what no what something
terrible is coming just give it to me
straight
for anyone who loved the flight
attendant did anyone love the flight
attendant i'm a fan of that so good love
love kayla well it's back on hbo max and
kaylee cuoco
is back for more nail-biting drama but
when it comes to marriage this flight
attendant is cool in her jets people
reports kaylie just divorced from carl
cook her second husband and she says
quote i will never get married again
she said she'd love a long-term partner
but marriage is absolutely not happening
and she said that people could quote her
and put that right on the cover
yeah yes and good for her if that's what
she wants i don't like it and i'll tell
you why i have have you ever been in a
position where you ate like a whole
pizza to yourself and you're like oh my
god i'm never eating pizza again
and then you know
a day comes around when you're like you
know what sounds good is some pizza and
i'm just telling you you may be saying
now drew i never want to get married
again but what about one day 30 years
from now you meet somebody who's your
person and it's important to them right
do you think maybe then you change your
mind nope no
no absolutely not what if they fed you
pizza if we brought it back around to
that would you
if you wrapped anything up in pizza i
feel like i'd be in
cnn reports that music icon dolly parton
says that there's only one person that
she would want to play her in a movie
and it's none other than tony
award-winning broadway powerhouse
kristen chenoweth
this makes so much sense she says
kristen is absolutely fantastic and if
there's ever a biopic she would be her
first choice i mean rossi
it's a no-brainer but i can
[Applause]
why am i going parliament and you're
going dolly parton i look like i i'm a
judge in a british
show
give me a gavel what is going on i don't
know but i am feeling myself in this sky
i stumble into the bed stumble in the
kitchen
look at me for myself a cup of ambition
watch out
kristin chenoweth i'm coming for your
gig and i am going to change legislation
[Music]